I think we've got a really good summary
there of Ronda santis and his uh his
path ahead as well as his chances at
winning the nomination chair of the
Republicans overseas are Greg Swenson
there thank you apologies for cutting it
short but you'll understand why this uh
this developing story uh coming out of
Central London uh very few details at
the moment but Metropolitan Police have
confirmed that a car has crashed into
the front Gates of Downing Street in
London uh this has come into US within
the last few minutes
um we do know
um that police say there were no
injuries so no injuries happened after
or during that crash and one person has
been arrested
um we uh can see some shots that we
can't bring you yet but we are um
scrambling to get our correspondent
there to find out what's happened our
Westminster Studio literally down the
road from Downing Street so we're
heading down there now to and to get
eyes on the scene and find out what is
going on but from what we can gather
from what we're being told is that there
is a um according now a long Whitehall
which is the main road running past
Downing Street as several government
departments based there of course at
number 10 Rishi sunak his office based
their um Chancellor at number 11 as well
it's a very secure area for anyone who
works in central London or has come as a
tourist there if you walk past Downing
Street there are heavy heavy Gates and
security uh bollards in place to stop
you from getting to Downing Street or
anywhere near the building itself you
have to go through the gates and then go
quite some way down to the end of
Downing Street to get to number 10 and
number 11 but cordons have been put in
place along Whitehall the road running
up to Downing Street so you can't get
anywhere near it at the moment we're
going to get as close as we can but that
car colliding um within the last few
minutes or so into the gates of Downing
Street nobody injured and one person has
been arrested
Matthew Thompson is in The Newsroom we
are as I said sending a correspondent
down to get eyes on the scene uh to
bring our viewers up today
um but Matthew the Metropolitan Police
not providing much detail at the moment
but just worth running us through what
we do know yes I mean what we do know is
really you can fit on the back of a
postage stamp it is very very limited
information but this is because it's
quite literally just happening as we
speak the Met police have told us that
no injuries have been reported in this
incident but one person has been
arrested and that's pretty much all we
know there are those some videos
circulating on social media which appear
to show the incident itself it looks
like from a couple of the videos I've
seen it's a small silver car which is
wedged against the gates there's police
swarming all around it and as you
rightly say there's not at least a
cordon in place along Whitehall
just getting a bit more detail here and
armed officers arrested a man at the
scene we understand it's on suspicion of
criminal damage and dangerous lot
driving that's the line just coming into
us from Metropolitan Police they've also
recapped that there are no reports of
any injuries and inquiries are ongoing
obviously this happened at around a 20
past four uh this afternoon so not that
long ago and so sorry Matthew just
wanted to update viewers on those new
lines there so we can incorporate that
into to what we know so far this
literally happening
um you know just half an hour ago I
think criminal damage or a suspicion of
criminal damage is an interesting one
and it would tally with what I was just
about to say in fact which is that
anybody who knows Whitehall knows dining
Street you can see and you can see if
you look online at some of these videos
the position of the car is such and the
nature of the barriers around the dining
Street gate or such that it's a very
difficult place to accidentally swerve
into if you see what I mean now that's
not to say we shouldn't speculate of
course that's not to say someone
couldn't do so but it might lend some
Credence to the idea that to get
yourself into the position that this car
appears to be in in some of the videos
is actually quite a challenging thing to
do unless it is somehow deliberate now
of course we must let due process take
its course but it is interesting
therefore that police are now telling us
they've arrested someone on suspicion of
criminal damage is it possible to tell
from the videos
quite high damage the gates are we just
we just can't see and of course as you
rightly say we're trying to get a camera
down there post taste as I'm sure plenty
of other organizations will be but it
doesn't look to be
completely crippling damage to the
dining Street gate at least from the
videos I've seen it's certainly not
hanging off its hinges although I
suppose you might expect that the gates
are are built to withstand considerable
Force given that they guard the The
House of the Prime Minister and the
chancellor but it doesn't look
completely like a disaster Zone but
nonetheless it is quite extraordinary
that a car has managed to get there if
it is an accidental uh position the cars
find itself in well I mean it's it's
very as I say it's at least difficult to
imagine how that's happened but if it is
potentially someone goodness knows what
protesting or or even more
even worse than that then it's it's
probably the worst place to do it
because it's the most guarded place in
Britain practically and police will have
been right on the scene armed police in
fact shouldn't be surprising that armed
police made the arrest because they're
the ones who who guard the gates of
dining street so at the moment very
little information coming into us but we
will endeavor to get you as much as
possible yeah we've just got we've just
got a bit more coming in now we actually
have some video that's been sent into us
from the scene this is from a viewer
Lewis McAllister this is obviously taken
it looks like from a bus
um as he made his way down White Hall uh
you can see there the car in front of
the gates at Downey Street the silver
car there with its boots open and just
to recap if you're just tuning in now to
Sky News uh we've just had this update
for the Metropolitan Police at around 20
past four so just over half an hour ago
the car you're seeing here on your
screen crashed into the gates of Downing
Street uh this video clearly taken a few
few moments after it happened because we
understand now that Whitehall is called
and off traffic being turned away from
that area what we do know about what
happened is that nobody was injured
armed officers arrested a man at the
scene and we're told by the Metropolitan
Police on suspicion of criminal damage
and dangerous driving Metropolitan
Police say inquiries are ongoing so this
happening literally within the last half
an hour We're sending our correspondence
from Westminster down to the scene and
to see what more information they can
get but obviously as Matthew was just
saying A Downing Street and probably one
of the most heavily guarded streets in
London Matthew and you were referring to
this video before we brought it to our
viewers um because it's uh it's on the
social media and we've managed to get
hold of it to bring it to people you
haven't got access to social media at
the moment
um and and you can just see the movable
barriers in front of the permanent
barriers in front of Downing Street you
know it's a heavily secured area call to
do that you know there's going to be
serious questions asked as to what the
intent was and how it was allowed to
happen exactly I mean I suppose that's
that's exactly the video I was referring
to and that's the point I was trying to
make you can see there it's quite clear
and as I say anyone who knows Downing
Street and many of us walk past it quite
frequently uh you can see that actually
to get itself into that position
requires quite a bit of maneuvering it
has to actually turn off the main road
on Whitehall get past a couple of those
um those silver temporary barriers and
then you know there's there's five or
six meters before it then reaches the
gates of dining street so as I as I say
look we can't we shouldn't we shouldn't
speculate it's possible someone swerved
in there but it does given the position
of that silver car as you can see
questions you rightly say should be
raised about exactly what it's doing
there in the first place and I think it
is interesting that police are telling
us that they have arrested a man on
suspicion of criminal damage and
dangerous driving and obviously as I say
a due process will take its course it's
not up to us to decide what what this
man's intentions were but it is
revealing that that's what police are
not telling us because it's not a
natural position for a car to be but
also what I was trying to say you can
see very clearly there in in those
images is that the gates of dining
streets are still very much standing it
doesn't look I mean again we're looking
at it from what looks like a bus and
from the other side of the street we
need to get a camera closer to it so you
can actually see the damage but at least
it looks from those videos oh there's
some better picture actually probably
from one of our cameras but it you know
it looks as if any damage to the dining
Street Gates is fairly minor but that's
hopefully because they're pretty well
reinforced Gates as I say in the most
well guarded Street in London
like a very calm scene there now
obviously I'm sure it was entirely
different just over half an hour ago
when this happened at around 20 past
four we're told by the Metropolitan
Police
um down by that camera on Whitehall just
by the gates of Downing Street is our
political correspondent Joe Pike who I'd
imagine has raced down from our
Westminster Studios and Joe tell me
about what's going on
what does he say Sarah Jane it does seem
quite calm at the moment the last few
minutes a large Cordon blocking almost
all of this street has been reduced so
we're far closer to this silver
hatchback car that you hopefully
continue on your screen now with its
boots open the police do seem calm not
on edge at all although there are a lot
of armed officers to Red police fans and
you can maybe hear in the background
some Sirens too unclear if they relate
to this investigation it all happened
about 40 minutes ago when as the Met
have confirmed this small gray hatchback
car collided with the front Gates of
Downing Street here on Whitehall Downing
Street for the last few decades that has
these very strong black metal gates
either end they were put up after some
Ira attacks and the risk of Irish
Republicans but it means that actually
the heart of power here the prime
minister's an office is very heavily
protected not just armed officers on the
gates but also airport style security if
you want to get up the gate and even
more to get get inside
investigations seem to be ongoing there
are officers having discussions next to
a couple of police cars slightly out of
shot but that investigation yet does
seem to be going on the fact that the
Cordon is far smaller now Sarah Jane
than it was 10 minutes ago that we are
far closer to that car suggests police
believe the risk of something else is
small and the sort of danger is is less
significant because we now know that
armed officers have arrested a man at
the scene on suspicion of criminal
damage and of dangerous driving there
are no reports at this stage of any
injuries but inquiries as you can see
are ongoing
thank you and your
something that I've experienced when
I've gone to to present from outside
Downing Street for big important
political events that airport Star
Security you have to have the right
accreditation to get in there
um you know the armed police or a
regular presence there
um on an average day
um you know this this is quite a
a difficult place to gain access to
um so you will imagine you know the
police dealt with this immediately and
that's perhaps why things are coming to
a close so quickly
yes and police are used to dealing with
protesters who are usually in a pen or
on the opposite side of the road you
know allowing protesters to voice their
uh concerns their their beliefs very
close to number 10 is sort of part of a
democratic process the police are used
to dealing with different individuals
and of course tourists as well and many
tourists come in close to the gate to
try and get a photo of the sign or get a
photo in in front of the gates trying to
get I don't know a sign of of a
political visit even though it's
actually quite difficult because the
road is longer than you might expect
they're used to dealing with lots of
different scenarios and certainly it
seems they dealt with this very quickly
not just arresting the individual but
clearing all of Whitehall the large
street that Downing Street comes off on
very very wide perhaps best known for
remembrance Sunday we're very close to
the senator half and you maybe can hear
the bells of Big Ben behind me as well
this street is normally packed with
people not just
tourists but people who work it within
the Civil Service Stoney Street's
opposite the ministry of Defense lots of
government departments that are down
this street and very quickly the police
seems to have seemed to have cleared all
people so they had a a secure empty Zone
to investigate what has happened the
fact that that large Cordon that went
all the way down a White Hall almost to
Parliament square has now been reduced
to a far smaller area far closer to this
gray hatchback car which was driven into
we understand the gates of Downing
Street that suggests the police believe
they are now in control of the situation
inquiries are clearly ongoing this
Cordon may stay up for a while but the
fact that armed officers have arrested a
man at the scene telling us that was on
suspicion of criminal damage and of
dangerous driving and the fact that
there are no reports of any injuries
suggest they believe some of the risk
here almost all of the risk here has now
been dealt with and the next stage is
investigating quite how this happened
who this individual was and what their
intent was
you are watching the NewsHour I'm Mark
Austin and we are staying with this
story which is an incident that has
happened at the entrance of Downing
Street at around 20 past four this
afternoon a car collided uh as you can
see there with the front Gates of
Downing Street no one has been injured
and one person uh we're told has been
arrested cordons have been put in place
and as you can see armed police are
there as they would normally be normally
be one has to say
at the entrance to Downing Street a very
well protected uh Street of course but a
White Hall which you could see on the
right of your picture there closed off
uh for the moment uh the gates were not
seriously damaged from pictures we have
seen
um
but they have arrested as I say a man
and that arrest was on suspicion of
criminal damage and dangerous driving
Joe Pike is down there at the scene for
us Joe just set the scene for us
well a strange atmosphere here mark But
police officers seem largely calm at
this moment in the last 10 minutes or so
the large Cordon blocking off the whole
of this street in central London where
all government departments or most
government Department space that Cordon
has been reduced to a far smaller area
so we are now far closer to the small
gray hatchback car which has been driven
into the gates of Downing Street Gates
that were installed about 24 years ago
in 1989 towards the end of Margaret
Thatcher's Premiership of course because
of the the threat of the IRA and there
was that mortar attack on John Major a
couple of years later decades ago you
could walk up and down a Downing Street
public could get very close to Prime
Ministers of course that has changed and
there is an incredibly high level of
security down this street not just a lot
of CCTV cameras but constant police
presence 24 hours a day and an armed
police presence there were armed
officers as there always are on the
gates of Downing Street those are the
ones who quickly arrested at this
individual oh it does seem now the
investigations are ongoing there are
quite a few unknowns here who this
individual was and I suppose Mark what
what the intent was how did he come to
drive into the gates of Downing Street
was this an accident or was it
intentional police those team calm there
are a lot of I suppose tourists and
people working in the offices here who
are trying to get home from work and the
armed police are staying outside the
gates of Downing streets around this car
as as those investigations continue it
happened about 40 minutes ago 20 past
four the car collided with the gates of
Downing Street one man was arrested by
armed officers at the scene that was on
suspicion of criminal damage and of
dangerous driving at this stage there
are no reports of any injuries but the
investigation by police is ongoing it's
not clear at this stage who is in uh
Downing Street who's in the cabin office
a lot of senior Ministers of course are
working there but I'm sure they're all
incredibly secure because whatever the
circumstances of this event the car was
stopped at the gates of Downing Street
the driver was arrested
yeah and there is a statement uh Joe
from the Metropolitan Police and it says
pretty much uh what we know at
approximately
4 20 this afternoon uh a car collided
with the gates of Downing Street on
Whitehall armed officers arrested a man
at the scene on suspicion as you say of
criminal damage and dangerous driving he
has been taken into custody no reports
of any injuries and the investigation is
ongoing an investigation which I assume
from the pictures we just saw
first of all involves a good search of
that car Joe
it certainly does the the back of the
car the boot of the car was open when we
arrived that is now closed there were no
offices directly around it
um it is possible in the in the coming
minutes uh we'll get even closer to it
if this Gordon is is taken down
certainly at some stage I suppose the
police will want to remove this car
maybe take it away for further
investigation and you'd imagine that the
individual arrested by police will be
questions it certainly seems that the
Met police officers who work at the
gates Downing Street aren't police acted
very very quickly of course there are
police stations very close to here
Charing Cross police station just off
Travis square at the end of a White Hall
being particularly closed that's where a
lot of these armed officers who work
within government and work within
parliament are based there was a quick
response with various vehicles I can see
uh two red police fans a couple of other
white people fans as well as police cars
blocking the road Whitehall remains
closed I suppose it will remain closed
while that investigation
proceeds but the fact that the far
larger Cordon the court was blocking
almost the whole length of Whitehall
this street in central London suggests
that the Threat Level the risk to the
public is has been considered to be not
significant we're now I don't know 50
meters from this this silver hatchback
car that's been driven into the front
Gates of Downing Street the police seem
very calm here not concerned of any sort
of ongoing incident what is happening is
that investigation is continuing and as
I say Mark they'll want to work out why
this happened was this intentional was
it an accident and who was the person
who was driving that car
um just to I mean that car the gates
what 150 200 yards to the actual door of
Downing Street then you have number 11
uh a little bit further on do you know
do we know the whereabouts of uh prime
minister and Chancellor
we don't have this uh this stage
certainly the Prime Minister was
appearing on television in London this
morning a big focus of government
ministers today has been the immigration
figures this morning so we've seen
senior ministers uh within Parliament
and a lot of ministerial cars have been
in Parliament but of course because
today is the start of recess the Whitson
recess is when the house Rises a lot of
parliamentarians and therefore ministers
will have returned to their
constituencies Whitehall and Parliament
is much quieter today than on a on a
normal day and that means I think the
the impact that this will have on the
lives of politicians and ministers may
not be that significant of course there
are other access points to A Downing
Street there is a back gate there are a
Gates through the the foreign office and
the treasury and other ways to get out
through the the cabin office so the fact
that this gray hatchback car has been
driven into the front states of Downing
Street is currently blocking it should
not affect in any way the movements of
the Prime Minister Rishi sunak and his
family or indeed a Jeremy Hunter
Chancellor both of whom of course who
live in Flats above at number 10 and
number 11.
if you just joined us you are looking at
pictures of the entrance to Downing
Street where a car has driven into the
gates of
uh Downing Street and the Metropolitan
Police say armed officers arrested a man
at the scene on suspicion of criminal
damage and dangerous driving he has been
taken into custody no reports we're told
of any injuries but an investigation
continue and as you can see
a considerable number of armed police on
the scene as they are normally but more
have now clearly arrived and Joe Pike is
as close as he can get and it's worth
saying Joe of course Downing Street and
Parliament itself
um increased protection over the years
and they are prepared for these sort of
things
they certainly are marked 24 hours a day
there are armed officers around
Parliament and around at number 10. you
can see I think uh perhaps a staff
member or a police officer trying to get
uh into the area close to that car it's
unclear who this woman is I don't know
if you can see her on screen of course
there are lots of people who work within
Downing Street in the cabin office
um the gates at either end of Downing
Street were installed in uh 1989 the
threat of the IRA meant that security
was heavily increased but it has been
increased over the years during due to
various threats and various attacks of
course that water attack when John Major
was prime minister in 1991 and more
recently the Westminster Bridge attack
which led to the death of a police
officer as well as a number of our other
individuals at Parliament there are
always armed officers here but not
normally as they are now standing in the
middle of the streets they're not often
accompanied by so many police vehicles
and of course we don't normally have
there's cordons with with red tape
saying police line uh do not cross that
is of course incredibly unusual but this
is perhaps one of the most secure
then you have to get down Whitehall of
course which at points is is heavily
guarded and then uh through gates to
Downing Street there are various blocks
to cars coming down not just the main
gates there are other ways bollards and
other uh bits of Kit to block cars
coming down the street but if you are an
individual you need to get
asked quite a lot of stages including
airport style security it is incredibly
secure area and there's lots of CCTV
outside as well as you can see a lot of
police officers now looking into it
seems the back windows of that car
though as a police officer either side
of the back of this gray hatchback car I
can see them wearing gloves
blue forensic gloves I'd presume to make
sure they preserve the evidence that
they are standing next to this silver
hatchback car I'm sure will be examined
very carefully over the next hour or two
they've just opened the boot of the car
it is unclear if there was anything in
it but that is something clearly Mark of
interest to these officers it doesn't
seem like there is any uh ongoing threat
here because we are now so close to the
ground a or silver hatchback card that's
been driven into the back of Downing
Street armed officers confident after
arresting this man at the scene on
suspicion of criminal damage and of
dangerous driving no reports at this
stage of any injuries but as you can see
the investigation is continuing these
two officers at the boot have not just a
blue forensic gloves on but they also I
think have clear evidence bags so
they're taking stuff out of the back of
this car of course I'm clear what that
may be whether it will be relevant or
not to the investigation but clearly
trying to preserve all items left at the
scene after this one individual was
arrested on suspicion of criminal damage
and of dangerous driving the
investigation Mark continuing here at
the gates of Downing Street Whitehall
this Central Street close to Trafalgar
Square between Trafalgar Square and
Parliament Square remains closed but the
fact that the police I seem pretty calm
suggests that they believe the risk the
ongoing risk the public is low
Joe uh we'll leave it there with you for
a moment and I'm joined by the former
Chief superintendent in the metropolitan
police Dal Babu
um good evening Dell and I just well I
mean clearly this
sort of thing the police are prepared
for it but alarming nevertheless
yeah absolutely it's very very early
days at the moment
um it's unclear whether this will be
terrorism related or mental health
issues but it would indicate there's
more issue of around mental health given
that the police are very very close to
the vehicle they've opened it up they've
made an arrest they don't seem to have
put any cordons any significant cordons
in place so to indicate that this is
something that they feel very
comfortable in terms of neutralizing and
dealing with immediately But ultimately
what they'd be doing at this time
sure
the registration number of the vehicle
checked and started doing intelligence
sales so they've been intelligent cells
straight away checking as much
information as possible and then making
decisions about the individuals they've
detained whether there's other
individuals involved whether they need
to make further arrests so so you'll be
a very very quick moving
um
scenario of events
yeah Dal and you're breaking up a little
bit um but if you can still hear me I
mean it is because of it is because of
the terror threat over the years that
Downing Street parliament of the
government buildings have become
increasingly secure but uh as you say
this incident there is a certain
calmness around everything from what I
can see on these uh pictures would
suggest that it's something else
yeah yeah absolutely so what you would
normally have if it was a terrorism
incident you would have a cordon put in
place you'd have specialist officers
brought in to search the vehicle uh you
would have a lot more caution uh what
we've got is police officers Milling
around they've opened up the vehicle
they seem to be right next to it so
there doesn't seem to be any concerns
about secondary devices there isn't any
significant accordance in fact from your
images Mark you can just see people
walking members of the public walking up
and down so that that doesn't seem to be
any particular concern I mean and as you
say over the years we've had more and
more security around buildings I
remember when I was a young PC you could
walk up down the street all the way to
number 10 and then after we had the IRA
attack and these Gates were put in place
and much more restrictions as we've seen
across all of the um key government
buildings
yeah and presumably
senior officers would be talking to the
Prime Minister and the chancellor should
they be there and just reassuring them I
assume yeah absolutely so so if there
was any genuine concerns uh the whole
place would have been called we've not
had that and yeah and you're absolutely
right to point out this is a residential
street certainly for uh the Prime
Minister and uh the chancellor and
um certainly the prime minister's got
children there and his wife would be
there so they'll be very very uh you'll
be very very keen to be reassured that
there is nothing of threat to the family
uh the the fact that we see members of
public walking up and down would suggest
that this very very early stages and
it's always very very difficult to make
a
um an announcement about what you may
think early on but given all the
evidence there this looks like to be an
isolated incident perhaps somebody with
mental health challenges somebody who's
got a grievance who's gone into uh
they've been arrested for Dangerous
driving and criminal damage no other
offenses that have been arrested for if
there was any suggestions of terrorism
they would be arrested for different
offenses
yeah and also
um I suppose you know in this case it's
pretty clear from what everybody is
saying from what the Met police is
saying from what we're seeing that no
shots were fired by the armed police so
um had it been as you were saying
earlier a a terror incident things may
have been very different
yeah absolutely I mean the the plea I
was a Firearms Commander for many years
and and actually some years the the
police didn't fire a single shot uh so
the police are being restrained they're
very well were well trained uh you would
have had a significant number of
firearms officers there it's one of the
most CCTV Place uh in in the country
um as we discovered with partygate and
so if there were any concerns then you'd
be having these resources moving in very
very quickly to deal with it and there
are police resources all around this
area I remember Scotland Yard is less
than half a mile away Parliament is a
few hundred yards away so there's police
officers there normal Patrol police
officer but also armed police officers
and we have a number of embassies in and
around the wider area
it's interesting you say of your
experience of uh of being a Firearms
officer I mean what goes through the
mind of an armed police officer in a
situation like this as the car comes
towards the gates it must be split
second decision making and very very
difficult
yeah absolutely so so I was a Firearms
commander and I and I think I was
incredibly impressed with the police
officers that we had going out Firearms
operations they had to carry out they
have to undertake a very very high level
of training uh and in some ways this is
what they've been training for all their
uh careers just to be in a situation
where they're able to deal with the
situation the fact that they are so
experienced and restrained
um indicates how well they've been
trained and at a time when the police
have had a lot of bad publicity this is
probably a good example of how the
Firearms officers have dealt this with
in an exceptional way I mean dare I say
if this was America whether we would
have had a different kind of scenario uh
where um shots are fired on a regular
basis whereas here
um the police are incredibly restrained
as they've shown with this particular
case and it doesn't get much more high
profile than somebody trying to run the
gates of Dentistry
yes I can I remember being in the United
States in Washington and there were
certainly
um a greater tendency to to to use uh
Firearms there when uh things like this
happen
yeah and I and I think what will happen
now is they'll they'll start looking at
what lessons they can learn uh is there
something that they'll inevitably be
debriefed involving all the officers uh
they'll be looking at
um some of the decision logs making sure
that CCTV is an appropriate place
they'll also have to deal with the media
there'll be a huge amount of media
interest not just locally but sorry to
up for you Daryl I just want to bring in
some um footage from BBC News Now
um which is uh of the moment if you
watch the center of the picture
um
there is the car going across and
um reasonably slowly you may have just
caught that the silver car just driving
across there it is uh and
and ending up I'm hitting the gates of
of Downing Street but as you can see
from those pictures there doesn't seem
to be a huge amount
of uh alarm or people running or it
seemed to happen all pretty slowly uh
Dal I don't know whether you can see
this
um I can yeah and that would indicate
that you know there may be a third
option you know we talked about
um terrorism or somebody who had been
unwell this could be a plane accident
yeah there's no indication there of
somebody speeding somebody could have um
just driven very very poorly so I think
you know I think you've got to keep all
your options open but at this stage
given the way the police have responded
and the images that we're seeing of the
vehicle moving very slowly towards the
gates it would perhaps indicate that
it's more likely to be uh either
somebody with some mental health
challenges or somebody who's just had an
accident
yeah okay uh Dal thank you very much for
uh your expertise on all this I'm joined
Now by Chris Candia who uh was at
Parliament uh apparently delivering a
petition and was escorted by police down
through Downing Street and happened to
witness uh What uh happened Chris tell
us what you saw and heard
to at Downing Street and we'd just gone
through security barrier having our IDs
checked and as we were reversing from
the security check to where you go
through to have your bags x-rayed
there's an Almighty smash at the front
gate which is meters away from us and
immediately we saw police scramble and
armed officers responded Bentley swiftly
and shouted at the man to get out of the
car this was a silver Toyota
um
uh well I'd say 10 and officers pointing
rifles at at the man
he was wrestled out of the car very
quickly and put down on the ground and
handcuffed and his pickle was insert we
were pushed through security as quickly
as possible and again brilliant response
from the police officers there they
formed the human shield to make sure
they were in the way at this stage we
have no idea what's happening uh it
could be a terrorist attack could be a
bomb attack could be an armed man and so
they they really put themselves between
us and the other people that were
delivering the petition we were
delivering a petition about the UK
welcoming Sudanese refugees in the same
way that we've offered wonderful
hospitality to ukrainians and we rushed
it to the back as far away from that
front gate as we could get uh push down
some stairs to build us in case anything
was to explode and then a few minutes
later I should out the back gate lots of
apologies that we couldn't deliver our
petition but they're putting everyone's
safety first we waited that gate and
pretty soon more police arrived some
people left Downing Street with a
recycle
um
compliment and then the whole place
became more and more shut down
yeah you say Chris you had a loud bang I
mean what was your initial thought
um it must have been pretty frightening
yeah
there were six of us there was
um
a lady from Ukraine a lady from uh Sudan
and some Sydney's gentlemen and you know
everyone was spending responded
incredibly uh calmly and bravely but you
know it was a smash but I thought
there'd been an explosion I thought
there might have been a shot fire but
you know that was just a loud noise of
the impact and suddenly it's armed
officers responding very quickly very
decisively shouting clear instructions
at the man about what to do he seems to
be a middle-aged man uh short stature
and um you know he he complied as uh as
he was asked to
right but there's no indication of what
you know it was about whether as you say
there was a we've had a police officer
on say it could have all be all sorts of
things from someone who simply had you
know driven very badly it could be a
mental health issue but the first
thought obviously as you mentioned there
is Terror but it clearly doesn't seem uh
that that is the case
yeah I I think the police use their
training to the utmost they needed to
reject a worst case scenario and respond
appropriately and they did and you know
we couldn't have been in better hands
I think they were definitely being
better safe than sorry you know it's
very difficult to round the front gate
of Downing Street it would be a pretty
bizarre uh maneuver to do that from the
rest of Whitehall so I think they made
the right choices under the
circumstances
yeah very difficult for them clearly I
mean we have got pictures that we've
just seen of
um the car Crossing uh Whitehall and
then
driving between those bollards and
um viewers can see it now
um and it all seemed to happen Chris
um very slowly
yeah I mean the first thing we hear
about it is this loud smash into the
gate and then we're seeing police
running and you know responding very
urgently to the situation so yeah I
haven't got the hindsight of seeing how
quickly he traversed Whitehall but but
again all I can do is just commend the
police for being consummate
professionals they were Brave completely
calm but you know absolutely decisive in
their action and just increases my
respect for the this police was
yeah okay Chris well listen uh we
appreciate your time thank you very much
indeed for uh coming on
and we can talk now to
uh uh correspondent Liz Bates who is
down there at uh the entrance or very
close to the entrance to uh Downing
Street Liz um give us a sense of uh the
scene
so the scene down here and you can
probably see it over my shoulder the car
that driving to the gates of Downing
Street is still there there are a number
of police outside some of them are
standing there to the cordons some of
them it seems are going through the car
meticulously I think trying to just
check it all over that's the scene at
the moment Whitehall is still shut down
from here up to Parliament Square there
are as you can imagine lots of people
Milling around here there are lots of
tourists here as they usually are
there's a huge amount of press here when
I was coming down here there were a
number of police cars with flashing
lights rushing down to Downing Street it
does seem at the moment that things have
calmed down a little bit the expectation
is I think that
quite soon this road will be opened up
we don't know in terms of who was in the
building in Downing street where the
prime minister is at the moment I can
tell you that because recess is coming
quite soon a lot of the MPS aren't here
so
Westminster itself is not full of
ministers and MPS as it usually would be
so that's really the scene down here at
the moment so I think what was quite
clear when I was coming down here was
that this isn't a situation where all of
Westminster is locked down Parliament
itself security seems to be at the same
level they're still letting people in
and out this incident seems to be quite
contained
to outside Downing Street and as we've
already reported this was just one
arrest of one man and now that we've
seen the footage it's quite clear that
um well it seems that this wasn't a sort
of uh very aggressive attack you can see
yourself the car sort of meandered over
almost into the gates of Downing Street
I think what's happening at the moment
is the police have shut everything down
they're assessing the situation it
doesn't seem that the security has been
ramped up across Westminster and I think
the expectation is that if anything
things will start to get back to normal
quite soon
yeah and as you uh work in Westminster
spend a lot of time walking around
Westminster Downing Street Parliament
and so forth and it is interesting that
uh security
for all the obvious reasons has been
substantially increased in recent years
a huge amount of time 1989 I mean it is
it is quite a long time but that was in
response to threats from the IRA before
that Downing Street was open there were
no big gates in front of it and people
could wander up and down but of course
we know that Downing Street Westminster
Parliament is a Target and we've seen
those incidents over recent years we at
the moment it doesn't seem like we're
putting this crash into the gates of
Downing Street into that category but
understandably there is huge amounts of
security here there are armed police all
over the estate many uh in Downing
Street it's not an easy place to get in
and out of it's something that I do on a
regular basis as a journalist but the
security there is very strict as it is
across the Parliamentary estate as you
would expect so unsurprising I think
that this incident
um whatever it was and I'm sure we'll
find out more details reasonably soon as
to what the motivation for this was but
this it does seem that it has been shut
down quite quickly and that is because
security here is understandably
incredibly high and when this happened
it was quite clear to me as I was coming
down that there were huge numbers of
police rushing to the scene there were
already many many uh on the gates there
are many that work in the building armed
police so that's why this I think was
brought under control quite quickly the
cordons were put out extremely quickly
the road was shut down as well and
that's because Westminster is I think
it's fair to say Old Times braced for
incidents like this and there was really
a very speedy and well thought through
processes that kick in quite quickly and
I think that's what's happened today
yeah we can see uh more police tape just
going out at the end of Downing Street
which might suggest that they are going
to
reopen it and just close that small area
but as one of our eyewitnesses just told
us Liz they're police acting with great
restraint
but it is clear they I mean they closed
Whitehall off certainly to vehicles and
to the public and pedestrians as well
um is that it was it was a wider area
closed you know
it doesn't seem like wider security
measures have been rolled out across
across Westminster and I think one of
the things that indicates to us the
severity of what's happened here is yes
Whitehall is closed cars are not going
up and down at the moment but there are
still plenty of people Milling around
and so I think that gives us an
indication that security services are
not clearing the entire area they're
going through the car but if they
thought there was anything really
dangerous that was that could still
happen this entire area I think would
have been cleared and I think the
opposite really of that is happening at
the moment it looks like instead of that
they're getting ready to reopen at this
area I think you're you're right as well
to talk about the Restraint of the
police because of course we have seen
the footage it wasn't the car certainly
wasn't moving it's um at any speed but
any anything that seems like an act of
aggression particularly against sounding
Street that's where the prime Minister
worked and all of his staff and there
are many cabinet ministers that work in
in and on this part of the estate
anything like that has to be treated
with the the utmost vigilance and it
does seem like from the eyewitness
eyewitness account the police acted very
swiftly but also with quite a lot of
restraint in the way that they dealt
with certainly the person that was in
the car and I think it would be it does
seem at the moment like there are no
there are no wider links in in terms of
that person that's been arrested but I
think we'll get more information on that
uh quite soon
yes and as you say and as our eyewitness
said the police did act with um uh
considerable uh restraint the current
terrorism Threat Level in Britain is uh
I think substantial which means
effectively that an attack is considered
likely so
um you know obviously they will be
worried about these sort of things and
increasingly
um as I say this security has improved
particularly around Parliament as well
where there have been
um attacks sort of random attacks uh
outside Parliament
yeah certainly it has been ramped up
there's no question of that and
understandably so because of those
attacks
um that we've seen and uh of course uh
some of them with fatal consequences so
the security services are always
um ready for for that type of incident
and there are well thought through and
well rehearsed processes that kick in
and I think we've seen some of that
happening today and I think it's worth
saying you know this is not an easy area
to police because on any given day there
are I mean first of all in Downing
Street journalists coming in and out but
um as I think the eyewitness was taking
a petition up to Parliament there are
people that come in and out of Downing
Street all the time there are
ministerial visits into Downing Street
and of course the Prime Minister going
in and out that's a difficult situation
to keep secure and at the same time
there's many many times when I have been
down
um to Downing Street where there are
protests very loud protests and there's
some sometimes you know many hundreds of
people gathered in the streets out here
outside Downing Street and outside
Parliament as well Parliament square is
a place where there are often protests
and so you can see the difficulty that
the police and the security services
have here these are government buildings
they require people to be moving in and
out of them constantly all day long
there are of course as well and I can
there's many people now gathered here
there are a lot of tourists in this area
so the police and security services are
constantly having to make assessments
about the level of security and of
course upfront foremost in everybody's
minds are previous incidents that have
happened here and I think
they try to strike a balance between
keeping this place as an accessible
workplace that doesn't feel like it's
entirely separate from the public and to
to try to accommodate some of the
protests that go on and at the same time
try to make sure that things are secure
and I think there will certainly be a
lot of reflection today on what happened
and how um and how the police outside
Downing Street responded
Liz we're just uh we've got a helicopter
there a shot there of the car uh that
came to rest alongside the gates I
wonder if we could just show the
pictures again of the car uh coming
across Whitehall because there's
um there's quite an interesting it's
interesting to see where the car came
from which was immediately opposite the
gates of uh Downey street now that
um I'm told has come from a street
leading to a mod car park
um and that means that effectively then
that that car
has come across from
um a secure area
which is uh interesting
um so it it it is not a a busy street
not just it comes from a car park uh
we're told which uh is uh belongs to the
ministry of Defense
yes and that's quite odd I I thought the
same thing Mark when I was looking at
that footage is it's not uh entirely
obvious where the cars come from but
it's it seems that it's just driven
essentially in a straight line and if I
look over there now there are Gates that
go across that car park so
um it would have had to come through
um come through those Gates and go over
to Downing Street and it was quite um it
was quite an odd scene when you look
back on the footage because it does go
very slowly so yes it certainly it seems
to have come from another bit of the
estate I should just say it does seem at
the moment like the roads are being
opened up again you can probably hear
the police behind me there shouting at
everybody to get out of the road now and
uh it seems like they're about to remove
these cordons that were put out when
this incident happened and open up this
street again which suggests that to the
security risk is now over and everything
is going to largely go back to normal of
course the car is still there but it
does seem like it's been checked over
and things are going to start opening up
Liz thanks very much it sounds as if the
police are certainly reassured about
that let's speak to Colin Morgan former
head of public order Branch at the
Metropolitan Police so Colin I mean what
are your thoughts about this it seems uh
well the the car drove certainly quite
slowly into the gates uh the police
acted with restraint says the eyewitness
that came on Sky News a little earlier
what do you what do you make of it all
yeah I think you're uh I think your um
assessment from your your previous
reporter was was pretty spot on I mean I
think the police will be keeping their
options open
um obviously
um could it be mental health could it be
drunkenness could it be anything
but um it could simply be a motorist
that got confused and realized where
that he was I mean you used the
terminology a little while ago Mark that
came to rest against the gates looking
at your Sky copter rare footage it's
probably as much that as anything it's a
very strange situation especially as you
say where it came from at Richmond
Terrace directly opposite Whitehall to
Downing Street which which is a car park
um and a car park close to the ministry
Defense building but I think the police
will be keeping their options open I
mean again looking at your footage I
think the officers that were searching
the vehicle you know they weren't in
white forensic suits the vehicle wasn't
being isolated because they were
concerned about it
um they were allowing people um they've
probably got some sort of cordons in but
they would allowing people to to walk
further up the street you could see them
up with the Scottish office Etc further
up the street they weren't pushing them
back so I think don't think they had any
concerns at any stage about the vehicle
and I know it's been mentioned a couple
of times now but you know I don't know
many countries in the world where
something that's happening that shots
wouldn't have been fired by the
officer's gardening
the um the sort of seat up of of the the
Prime Minister
um you know so all credit to the
officers for using the training and
assessing the situation and not open
fire I'm sure they would have opened
fire if they felt we need to but you
know all credit to them very much in the
split second that they had to make those
decisions which
it was just how good um British police
Firearms officers are yeah it's a point
well made and I mean it's very difficult
for these police officers these armed
officers because the expectation
um you know of what they are waiting for
is something very serious and you know
as you say it is the the home of the
Prime Minister the chance that they are
protecting the Prime Minister and
Chancellor and they are expecting and
trained to expect something to happen
but in this case it just seemed to have
been dealt with uh calmly yeah yes
indeed indeed and you know he seems to
have been arrested pretty quickly and
that's that's reassurance you know and
they seem to have assess the situation
pretty quickly again from a from from a
citizen's point of view that's good to
know as well but you know they they are
trained to to fire as a last resort and
sometimes that last resort can be in a
split second but you know they are
trained to as a last resort they are
trained to take the situation in and to
apply
um the the threat and risk that they
feel before they pull that trigger and
because they know the consequences of
pulling that trigger if there says
someone who has just got confused or who
has unfortunately drunk or has got
mental health issues as opposed to a
terrorist which as we saw in 2017 you
know not that long ago a terrorist um or
is a couple of times using a similar
sort of tactic where they use the
vehicle as a weapon
um that's the reason that you have seen
you know the the called hostile vehicle
mitigation you have seen a lot of the
the buildings not just government
buildings but buildings all across
London and the major cities have um have
reinforced Gates and concrete blocks Etc
and put in place as your reporter said
you know Downing streets 25 years ago
when when I was a young officer
the public can walk straight up there
you could walk up on the other side of
the road so that you know that was then
closed and then they put in place these
very strong Gates that you can see
you've got exactly this scenario
um but or maybe a more Sinister scenario
where a terrorist or someone similarly
with similar intent is going to use a
vehicle to try and um get into Downing
Street for whatever reasons to um to
then come out their their attacks but
I'm getting the feeling but with this by
the pictures that I'm seeing from your
uh from your from your uh your channel
and your and what your reporters on Cena
saying I I'm thinking the police are not
thinking it's it's that Sinister
well just to interrupt you there Colin I
apologize for that um there was a little
bit of information we're getting which
would hint
um quite heavily at what you're saying
because we understand that the incident
is being dealt with by local police now
in Westminster and that uh certainly at
the moment counter Terror and police are
not involved in this
yes that that doesn't surprise me at all
but it would have gone through the
process counter-terrorism command would
have been consulted
um there would have been some
intelligence work done on the individual
on the car etc etc and then if need be
it would have been escalated to a senior
officer called the senior National
coordinator so Deputy assistant
commissioner level within the
Metropolitan Police who is the ultimate
decision maker as to whether something
is declared a terrorist incident or not
I strongly suspect it wouldn't have got
that far
um in relation to this one and it would
have been passed back to the the
criminal investigation department for
the local Borough which as you just said
Mark is is Westminster to deal with the
chap
um for whatever they see fit um and
whatever the evidence indicates and they
they would have access to the very CCTV
a lot of CCTV cameras around
um Downing Street Etc so they'll have a
fair idea what's been happening they'll
have probably given an account of what
what happened whether he got confused or
whether he doesn't make issues or
something
and some some other sort of illness or
something along those lines and and um
the mere fact that um I think your
reports will say that traffic's opening
up again and that the local
the local police are dealing with really
tells that it's it's maybe at worst a
criminal offense but more lately maybe
dangerous or careless driving or
something along those lines yeah exactly
uh these things happen for all sorts of
reasons and uh in this case mercifully
Colin it looks as though uh uh certainly
oh thank goodness not involved thanks
very much thank you very much thank you
coming on the program Joe Pike is down
there in uh Westminster what we can say
is it uh it's a beautiful day at
Westminster Joe Pike is there and Joe
you've got some information I gather
about the whereabouts of the Prime
Minister
yeah we understand now Mark that he was
within Downing Street at the time this
uh silver Kia drives into the front
Gates he'd been due to depart number 10
anyway but uh left very soon uh after
the Times newspaper publishing a video
of his armored motorcade leaving the
backstage back Gates of Downing Street
if you look around here A White Hall is
now open to traffic both ways so cars
bicycles coming down the streets
earlier there were police officers with
blue forensic gloves searching through
the boot the boot of this silver
hatchback car and putting some items
into evidence bags that has now stopped
there are no police officers anywhere
close to this silver Kia hatchback and
also the registration plate has been
taken off the back of the car of course
it's a very highly secure part of town a
huge amount of armed police here 24
hours a day mark it seems like they
reacted pretty quickly but the fact that
they are calm the police are calm the
fact The Cordon was reducing now the
hold of the street has been opened
suggests that they're pretty confident
they know what has happened even though
we do not know quite yet what has the
fact that we also know the incident is
being dealt with by the local Borough
Force by Westminster not by
counter-terrorism police suggest they
don't think this is Terror related we
know that one individual was arrested at
the scene very soon after on suspicion
of criminal damage and of a dangerous
driving no reports at this stage of any
injuries but clearly because of the
nature of this because of this location
at the heart of power outside the prime
minister's home that is why there is so
much media interest so many tourists
who've stopped and so many protesters as
well but but at this stage the
examination of the car seemed to have
stopped the police investigation that
seems to be continuing sure we
understand now markets being dealt with
by the local
police not by counter-terrorism commands
of Downing Street
yeah okay Joe thank you very much let's
just uh recap if you were just joining
us uh as you can see there
there has been an incident at the gates
of Downing Street a a car collided with
the front Gates of uh Downing Street no
one has been injured and one person has
been arrested the driver of that car has
been arrested cordons were put in place
very quickly uh to um
uh in in Whitehall to close that to
close white Auto vehicles and to
pedestrians uh Whitehall is now uh
reopened which is a sign that the police
are not too concerned about this another
sign is that it's being dealt with as uh
Joe Pike was saying there by local
police Westminster police not by uh
counter terrorism uh police so things uh
slowly getting back to normal in
Westminster Liz Bates is there and so uh
well Liz the Prime Minister was there
and the the chancellor also was in
Downing Street and they no doubt will
have been reassured uh in the last few
minutes by senior officers about what's
going on
oh certainly they'll have been caught in
constant con Constant Contact I should
say uh with the security services we do
understand the Prime Minister was on the
estate when this happened in Downing
Street and the chancellor as well so
that just shows you uh the high stakes
here anything that happens like this a
car crashing into the front of Downing
Street has to be treated like a
potential attack on the Prime Minister I
think he has left now but
that's why there are there is so much
Security in this area you can see now
and obviously we we just heard as well
that this is now being dealt with by
local police we can see as well uh that
the car that they were looking through
it and sort of gathering evidence and
they they seem to have stopped doing
that now it does seem like this is all
being scaled down quite quickly this
Road Whitehall had been completely shut
down when I came down here about half an
hour ago in the way of the incident and
now it has all been opened up again the
police coordinates have been removed
there isn't a huge amount of activity
now going on behind me although the
police are still here monitoring the
situation but as you can see cars coming
up and down it's much more back to
normal as it usually is here there are
still lots of journalists of course
reporting on the incident but people
wandering up and down the street lots of
tourists and as you can see there's
usually some sort of protest over on the
other side of the street and that is
that sort of kicked off again so very
much uh business as usual I think it's
fair to say here in Danish here just
outside Downing Street but yes I mean
having looked at that footage it does
seem like the cart came from just across
the road there behind some gates so
it'll be interesting to find out what
the motivation of the driver was and at
the moment of course it does seem like
it's not being treated like a terrorist
incident or anything like that
yeah things getting back to normal
clearly in Whitehall Liz but
nevertheless at 20 past four this
afternoon for the people Milling around
there and civil servants leaving their
offices and tourists as you say it would
be pretty frightening to have seen this
and for the police themselves an
alarming moment
it really it will have been in those
moments before they can make an
assessment of what's really happened
this is a a place to work right in the
heart of Westminster right in the heart
of government and it it operates in a
reasonably open way people come in and
out of Downing Street they come in and
out of parliament it is an operational
workplace but of course we know that it
is also a target for all kinds of
incidents and we've seen those incidents
play out in the past you know I was on
the estate back in 2017 when there was
an attack that ended up with the loss of
life and I think this is foremost in the
minds not least of the security services
but at that moment that was a very scary
day we were all locked in Parliament for
hours and of course the consequences
were entirely different it was an
entirely different type of incident but
I think that is what is sometimes
certainly mindset of the police they're
always braced for these moments and the
processors kick in quite quickly as they
did today but as well for the staff
sitting in the offices there there's
always that period where they don't know
the severity of what's happened and I
think that can be quite a a scary place
to be and thankfully it does seem like
today nothing more has come of this we
see the footage it's it's slightly odd
but it certainly doesn't look like an
attack in the way that we've seen in the
past
but those police officers live in the
real world and the real world is that
the terror Alert in this country is
substantial which means that an attack
is likely so that is uh you know on
their minds day in Day Out
oh no question in this
amount of security
in Downing Street something we go into
Downing Street on a regular basis and
there are quite a few layers of security
that you have to get through and it's
the same in Parliament and it is because
this place understandably you know the
prime minister is working behind those
Gates today the chancellor was in
Downing streets as well it can be a
Target and we we are you know right in
the heart of London here and there are
always protesters and there are lots of
people walking up and down Whitehall and
people going in and out to work and I
think we had an eyewitness on the
program earlier who said that they'd
taken a petition up to Downing Street
that happens on a regular basis and so
there's always that balance to be struck
of allowing this place to operate as it
should do as a workplace but also to
make sure that the security level is
high in case something like this happens
and we saw all those processes kicking
today but no doubt they will reflect on
them for the future
for the future uh
case something like this happens again
it's something they are always prepared
for okay Liz thanks very much indeed and
just to recap a man has been arrested on
suspicion of criminal damage and
dangerous driving after a vehicle was
driven into the gates of Downing Street
much more at the top of the hour
foreign
[Music]
Chancellor Jeremy Hunt was also in
Downing Street we now know
counter-terrorism police are not
involved in the investigation and the
road uh White Hall
is open again after being closed for
some time to both vehicles and
pedestrians and that is the situation at
the moment the car staying there at the
gates of Downing Street Joe Pike is as
close as he can get to the scene Joe
what's happening there now
almost two hours Mark after that very uh
frightening incident things have come
down firstly because of course we're so
close to this silver Kia hatchback
that's been driven into Downing Street
we're so close because the Cordon which
blocked this road uh for more than an
hour has now been uh reduced but of
course at 20 past four when this
incident occurred police officers here
members of the public people who work
within the cabin officer number 10 did
not know what had happened and of course
six years ago with the Westminster
Bridge attack it was a car driving into
pedestrians which which started uh that
that attack a number of people die
including of course a police officer who
was working
at the house of parlor Houses of
Parliament of course it became clear I
suppose within 10 minutes that this was
not as serious as some had been warring
of course I'm pleased who work here 24
hours a day may have initially warned
this was part of a number of attacks did
not know who the individual uh was
whether they were armed or whether they
had some uh form of a knife certainly
the individual arrested was arrested for
two things one dangerous driving
criminal damage and the fact as you say
that the campseries and Commander not
dealing with it since local police
suggests that it was not nothing too
serious certainly not a terrorist
incident certainly speculation about
what could have happened whether it was
an accident in terms of driving whether
somebody has had mental health problems
and launched an attack certainly we know
that investigation has been going on for
the last hour or so we've seen police
officers with blue forensic gloves
searching through the boot of this car
taking some items out and putting them
in plastic evidence bags we know that
the Prime Minister Rishi sunak was in
the building at 20 past four when this
incident happened he left via the back
gate soon after his motorcade left
although we're told he was planning to
leave at Downing Street at that point
anyway certainly there's always been
attention around this part of
Westminster because it is the site of
prime ministers coming and going of
world leaders meeting the Prime Minister
and of course because there was a
history
of terrorism attacks here as well we
know that these gates at Downing Street
have been here since
1989 put up in response to the IRA
threat and of course just two years
later in 1991 during John Major's
Premiership now was that mortar attack
on Downing Street hitting the Rose
Garden Of course certainly today
absolutely no no sign that this is
Terrorism related we know one individual
has been arrested on special criminal
damage and of dangerous driving we know
there are no injuries and the local
Borough Police Force Westminster are
dealing with this are not the terrorism
command but of course police officers
Mark did not know that at 20 past four
met police officers are trained in
Dynamic risk assessment to a second by
second assess the risk that is why such
a broad area of Western so all the way
down Whitehall was immediately cleared
uh cordoned off all tourist workers
taken out of the area so they could
assess the risk to those within a
Downing Street as well as to members of
the public at this stage the police seem
to be pretty calm there is no
freneticism at all those who had been
searching the car and taking pictures of
that car have now left the scene but we
understand that investigation is ongoing
to understand who this individual was
certainly the registration place on the
back of the car has been taken off but
it is a silver Kia hatchback but 20 past
four Mark was driven into the front
Gates of Downing Street that individual
arrested soon after yeah and Joe
um it appears calm now from all the
pictures that we are seeing but as you
say at 20 past four uh it would have
been a very different scene with people
Milling around tourists civil servants
leaving after a day's work and and
certainly the armed police of course
there but for the people it would have
been very frightening for the armed
police uh certainly alarming
exactly Mark especially when they lost
one of their own PC Keith Palmer six
years ago tour a terrorist attack just a
couple of hundred meters from here the
police officers most of the moms who
work here
uh
affecting UK democracy protecting our
elected officials and also of course
protecting others who are taking part in
the Democratic process we heard earlier
from people delivering petitions to
number 10. they're of course protesters
across the road on the other side of a
Whitehall uh protesting reasonably
peacefully but the police officers who
work here and uh cover this place 24
hours a day do it in many uh in many
different ways of course there are large
marches smaller protests and also some
okay eccentric individuals who are here
they have such a broad range of
situation they've got to look after not
just the protesters outside but often
very high profile individuals world
leaders coming inside they seem to
reacted fast because you can hear Mark
there are protests ongoing even though
the incident itself and this car being
driven into Downing Street seems to have
calmed down
yeah I think if the protesters are back
we can safely say things are getting
back uh to normal but uh just to be
clear Joe both the Prime Minister and
the chancellor were in Downey street at
the time
exactly Rishi sunak was in Downing
Street of course he lives above Downing
Street in a flat he was still within
number 10 working there today a big day
for the government say but of course
those immigration figures uh being
released he left the area around number
10 in his motorcade soon after we
understand he was always planning to
leave Jamie hunt of course working there
too and living in a flat above number
10. they are all uh secure it doesn't
seem like the investigation is ongoing
but of course at 20 past four this
afternoon a pretty frightening situation
for police officers and those who work
within Downing Street when that car was
driven into the front Gates by one
individual who's now been
arrested
okay Joe thank you very much indeed I
think we can also speak to Liz Bates who
is uh
uh in the area and Liz um we've seen
these pictures of the car
Crossing White Hall
um quite slowly and moving through the
bollards to the gates and and and
hitting the gates it all seemed to
happen quite slowly and it's quite
interesting where the car came from
because it wasn't it wasn't a public
road is that right
yes Mark that's certainly what it looks
like and I I share your view of that
footage because I think when we heard
initially and we all of course rushed
down here to find out what was going on
that a car had hit the gates of Downing
Street that of course sounds like a
potential attack and then you see the
footage of what actually happened and
the car was actually moving quite slowly
I can see based on that footage I think
at where the car came from and it does
look like a secure car park it's behind
uh Gates and that person would have had
to be let in and out of that car park
and then as you saw in the footage drove
extremely slowly across behind me and
into the gates of Downing streets and by
the time that I got here that car was
still there even though uh the the man
who was in it had been arrested and
removed from the scene at that point it
did have the boot open and uh for the
last hour or so the police and Security
Services have been picking through it
meticulously I think trying to make sure
that there is no further security threat
from that vehicle but it is still behind
me at the moment
um where it was when it crashed into the
gates of downership and I think what you
can also quite clearly see is that it
wasn't unsurprisingly given the speed
that it was going a particularly high
impact crash so of course that does
raise questions about what on Earth has
happened here and I think uh certainly
given the scene given all the
information that we have it's being
dealt with by the local police
everything has been opened up in terms
of White Hall cars and as you can see
behind me just moving in a normal way
all the police clubs have been taken
down that suggests to us that it it
really it wasn't an attack that we might
have been concerned that it might be
right at the beginning when we heard
this it seems like something else has
happened and I think the question is
what what was the motive nation of the
person that did that there's already
some fuzzy photos I think of that
individual circulating but I think we'll
uh it'll be interesting to get more
information on who he is and why on
Earth this has happened today
right and the police
um arresting him no word yet I assume on
you know his state of mind or what was
what what was the purpose of this or how
it happened
well that's still I think what's up in
the air because of course the first
thing that comes into your mind when you
hear that a car has driven into the
gates of Downing Street is that this is
some sort of attack some sort of uh
terrorist attack because we know that
this is an area uh that is a big Target
for that and there have been incidents
before the latest of course uh in 2017
which ended in a completely different
way but that is at the Forefront of
people's minds and then when you see
what's actually unfolded today clearly
it was something completely different
and I think now understandably the
spotlight will turn to the man in the
car and what was going on in his mind
because it's not clear that there was
any wider motivation to what happened
today and even looking at the footage
it's not clear that this was in in any
way an intentional attack so I think
that will be the information that we'll
be trying to seek next why why did this
happen in this way
yeah Liz thank you very much indeed
um as we can see now it looks as though
the police are preparing to remove that
vehicle Joe Pike is uh right there so it
it looks as if they're about to um take
take that car Away Joe
it does Mark in the last a minute or two
this police truck with a crane on the
back has turned up and police officers
look like they're preparing to lift this
silver Kia hatchback onto the back of it
and take it away perhaps for further
forensic investigation although we
should say the police officers who were
searching it earlier were not in the
sort of white protective suits you
sometimes see at crime scenes they were
though wearing blue forensic gloves and
they were putting items from the boot of
this car into clear plastic evidence
bags so the investigation does look like
it is ongoing and moving pretty quickly
because it is less than two hours since
this incident since 20 past four when
the car was driven into the front Gates
of Downing Street the police reacting
pretty quickly to neutralize the threat
to arrest the individual who'd been
driving that car
and to take him away handcuff him and
taken away also search him uh of course
we know that Richardson prime minister
the chancellor Jeremy Hunt were both
within Downing Street Mr sunac has now
left in his motorcade through the back
but certainly at the start this must
have been a pretty a frightening
incident the police response initially
was to close off the whole of Whitehall
this long Broad Street at the heart of
Westminster most recently of course the
route of the big coronation procession
also well known on on Remembrance Sunday
when the cenotaph is at the center of
those commemorations it was closed
initially for maybe around an hour all
individuals tourists people who work
within government in these government
departments around Whitehall all of them
are removed so you have a sterile Zone
firstly because of the investigation but
also because of the Potential Threat as
police worked out who the individual was
and whether there was any ongoing danger
for the car or of course ongoing Danger
from from other attacks police officers
here well aware that 60 years ago one of
their own was killed in a terrorist
attack just a couple of hundred meters
away on Westminster bridge and at the
gates of
um the Palace of a Westminster so
reacting pretty fast what met police
officers are trained to do their Dynamic
risk assessment to neutralize the threat
our friend the individual who was
searched and arrested and taken away
they have been searching the back of
this car as I say putting evidence into
evidence back they've taken the
registration plate off the back they've
also been taking photos now there is an
individual in a high vis a jacket
looking at the tires I think preparing
Mark to take this car away put it on the
back of a truck and remove it to
okay Joe uh thanks very much indeed if
you're just joining us here's what we
know so far about this a man has been
arrested after a car that car you can
see uh there hit the main gate of
Downing Street police say there were no
injuries the Prime Minister was in
Downing Street at the time the car
crashed into the gates also the
chancellor Jeremy Hunt was in uh Downey
Street as well uh
counter-terrorism police not involved in
this investigation it is local
Westminster police
who are involved in the operation a man
was arrested taken away in handcuffs as
Joe Pike was saying on suspicion of
criminal damage and dangerous driving
more than that we do not know in terms
of uh his uh intention
well as we watch these pictures at the
gates of Downing Street joining me now
is shabnan chaudry former detective
superintendent with the Metropolitan
Police good evening uh thank you for
being with us and I I mean look the good
news is that this uh has turned out not
to be terrorism Whitehall has reopened
and uh everything is pretty calm I just
wonder what you make of it all
yeah good evening Mark uh very very
quick fast time events unfolded there
over at uh Downey street we have to
remember as your colleague said earlier
that uh six years ago
um PC Keith Palmer was killed and along
with a number of other people uh they've
contained the area very very quickly
they're cordoned off the area much wider
as they would do because they don't know
what the situation was at the time could
have been terrorist related so they've
got to think about what has happened
there and if there was any likelihood of
any other incidents occurring but it
would appear either they've spoken to
the individual concerned or they've done
their research very very quickly they
work very closely with counter-terrorism
officers they've accepted right now that
this is not a CT issue and now they are
removing the vehicle as I understand it
but
um very very quick to contain that local
area and obviously to maintain Public
Safety yeah CT counterterrorism issue
and we're glad about that but so
difficult uh for the armed officers
involved because the we're talking about
split-second decisions here aren't we
absolutely and most the officers that
would have worked in and around Downing
Street would be very well trained in
terms of situations like this but you
have got to make them very fast quick
time decisions in respect of what is
actually unfolding in front of your very
eyes you've got uh which is soon as the
prime minister in Downing Street a
number of other
um higher profile people within the area
and also what's going on outside so you
know I I have to give respect to all the
officers present to contained that very
very quickly and I think also as your
colleague has said the vehicle crashed
into the gates there and it would appear
at this stage and the investigation is
still underway but it does not appear
that it was a deliberate act but only
time will tell
and because of the obvious threat that
uh
um to this country the the the security
at Downing Street and at Parliament and
to other government buildings
um has increased dramatically in in
recent years
yes they can't take absolutely anything
for granted and the fact is that they
will still maintain a high profile
um uh visibility around the area uh this
evening or probably in the following
days because uh they want to be clear
that everything is there are no serious
issues here that will unfold in the
coming days uh given some of the um
sweats that the uh the UK has faced in
recent years
and the reaction of the police I mean
Whitehall was closed very quickly to
pedestrians and and to vehicles
um this happened at 20 past four in the
afternoon but uh already uh Whitehall
opened to Vehicles now and as you can
see there people being allowed pretty
close to the gates of of Downing Street
yeah when you think about some of the
planning that's gone on in the last
couple of years you've had the king's
coronation you've had the state funerals
the Met would be very very up to date
with um how they would want to proceed
in a situation like this so officers
will be well and truly trained they'll
be well and truly brief they'll be
senior officers at the Strategic
operations room that are giving the
instructions and commands very very
quickly to ensure that the safety of
those within Downing Street and The
Wider public is maintained
okay thank you uh very much indeed for
uh joining us this evening well earlier
we spoke to Chris Candia who was
actually in Downing Street uh when this
happened handing in a petition or trying
to hand in a petition uh when the car
crashed into the gates uh I spoke to him
earlier this is what he had to say
then Almighty smash at the front gate
which is meters away from us and
immediately we saw police scramble and
armed officers responded gently swiftly
and shouted at the man to get out of the
car this was a silver Toyota
um
but I'd say 10 and officers pointing
rifles at at the man
he was wrestled out of the car very
quickly and put down on the ground and
handcuffed and his pickle was then
searched we were pushed through security
as quickly as possible and again
brilliant response from the police
officers there they formed the human
shield to make sure they were in the way
at this stage we have no idea what's
happening uh it could be a terrorist
attack could be a bomb attack could be
an armed man and so they they really put
themselves between us and the other
people that were delivering the petition
we were delivering a petition about
at the UK welcoming Sudanese refugees in
the same way that we've offered
wonderful hospitality to ukrainians and
we rushed it to the back as far away
from that front gate as we could get uh
push down some stairs to build us in
case anything was to explode and then a
few minutes later I should out the back
gate lots of apologies that we couldn't
deliver our petition but they're putting
everyone's safety first we waited at the
back gate and pretty soon more police
arrived some people left Downing Street
with a recycle
um
compliment and then the whole place
became more and more shut down everyone
was responded incredibly uh calmly and
bravely but you know it was a smash but
I thought there'd been an explosion I
thought there might have been a shot
fire but you know that was just a loud
noise of the impact and suddenly it's
armed officers responding very quickly
very decisively shouting clear
instructions at the man about what to do
he seems to be a middle-aged man uh
short stature and um you know he he
complied as as he was asked to
so all pretty terrifying there for Chris
uh all very alarming for the police and
uh he uh reported they're quite a bang
when that car crashed into those
um Gates although it wasn't going that
fast if pictures that we have seen this
evening are anything to go by the car
came across you can see there across
White Hall and uh slows down before
crossing the pavement there are bollards
there there's a gap in the bollards and
then you can
um go through to the gates and he that
car hit the gate where it came from is
interesting because the street uh
directly opposite uh
um Downing Street where that car
has emerged from is actually a private
road it belongs to the mod it leads down
to a car park an mod car park so it
looks as if from those pictures that
that car has come from a what would be a
secure location uh
and drives directly across
Whitehall and into those Gates and
people
as you can see Milling around walking
along Whitehall don't seem that alarmed
by what has gone on but police armed
police were there used huge restraint in
the circumstances it had to be said
because these are people
uh living in a world where there is a
substantial is the word for it at the
moment Terror alert and
um that means that an attack is likely
that is what the government has the
terror alert set at so the police are
living in that kind of world and when a
car comes careering towards even slowly
towards the gates it would be pretty
alarming for those officers and as we've
heard it is uh there will be many
countries around the world where there
would have been uh shots fired in
circumstances like this but not here
happily a man was arrested he was taken
away by police it is being dealt with
we're told by Westminster police local
officers in Westminster are interviewing
the man significantly he is not being
talked to by counter-terror police and
so clearly at the moment at least this
is not being treated as Terror related
Rachel venables is in Whitehall close to
the scene Rachel just give us a sense of
what's going on now
well it's just over 2
and of course in that time a huge Street
of Whitehall was closed down entirely
armed police officers rushing in to
search the vehicle the car that silver
Kia which at 20 minutes past four slowly
drove across the road just over to my
left here as you were mentioning already
where there is a car park for the mod it
crossed the road at quite a slow pace
quite surprisingly and it ended up you
should just be able to see past the
police car there where it still resides
this silver Kia hitting the gates of
Downing streets an enormous of course
police operation as she would expect
responding to that a man has been
arrested on suspicion of criminal damage
and dangerous driving crucially the
Metropolitan Police we understand have
not brought in counter-terror officers
this is being dealt with at a local
level by a Westminster police officers
and we've just had a statement in the
last few minutes from the Metropolitan
Police confirming that fact this is
something that Sky News had been
reported on for quite a while in the
past 20 minutes or so some activity here
the investigation side of things seems
to have ended we saw police officers
going through the car obviously they
removed the man inside they took out at
one point a white sheet then it looked
as though things were widening down and
a pickup truck actually arrived in the
last 10 20 minutes or so and it stood
and it sat for quite a while we thought
perhaps it was going to be moving the
car away but now it's parked a little
way further down White Hall at the
cenotaph so clearly officers perhaps
starting to get ready to think about
moving this vehicle on as the rest of
Whitehall starts to get back to a
semblance of normality you'll be able to
see the traffic around me they've
reopened the road about an hour ago
people have been able to come past but
it's a strange sense in the air here
people aware of of how nervous How
concerned those officers would have been
of course two hours ago and now there's
just that Curiosity for members of the
public tourists workers everybody in
between turning up and trying to
understand what happened here as the
police of course no doubt in a statement
somewhere in Westminster are questioning
that individual at the man who's been
arrested after that car hit the gates of
Downing streets at 20 past four a huge
operation no doubt for the police to try
and understand what's happening but at
the moment counter-terror officers not
involved that really is a crucial
headline I think to take away from a
very dramatic afternoon
okay Rachel thanks very much indeed just
to recap a man arrested after this car
was driven into the main gate of Downing
street we will have much more on this
story after the break
[Music]
thank you
foreign
feet or at the gates of Downing Street a
man has been arrested on suspicion of
criminal damage and dangerous driving
after the vehicle you see there a silver
Kia car
crashed into the gates at around 20 past
four this afternoon uh
the car has been seen we've seen
pictures of the car moving slowly across
Whitehall
from an mod compound area Car Park area
moving across Whitehall slowing down as
it crossed the pavement just behind the
car there and are driving into the into
the gates and the man inside the car was
arrested and has been taken away by
police the Metropolitan Police say no
one has been hurt no shots were fired
and it is understood that
counter-terrorism police are not at this
stage involved in the investigation uh
former met police officer Chris Hobbs
joins me now thank you very much for
being with us Chris I just wonder what
you
you think of what uh you've seen this
evening
yeah I mean I think generally speaking
the Metropolitan Police and its officers
will be fairly pleased with what's
occurred in terms of their reaction to
it as you know the met and policing
generally has been getting a little bit
of a hammering over the last few days
and weeks but I think there will
obviously be a review here but I think
generally speaking it worked well nobody
got hurt
um fortunately tourists weren't in the
way of the car because obviously you get
tourists congregating outside the gates
police were able to move very quickly
those armed police that were always
there to apprehend the individual
concerned
and doubtless as I say there will be all
sorts of inquiries going on at this
moment in time there'll be checks on the
gentleman who was arrested is he known
the police has he known the security
services and so on and so forth
um there will be probably a forensic
examination of the car when it's taken
away there may even be searches of his
home address just to make sure that
there's no hint of any sort of terrorist
involvement as I said he may have mental
health issues it could possibly simply
become ill but there will be an
investigation but generally speaking I
think at the moment the police will be
quite pleased hey no one's been hurt and
secondly their reaction to it which
again resulted in no one being hurt but
one gentleman arrested and further
inquiries will continue
but Chris how difficult is it for police
officers particularly armed police
officers doing the job that they are
doing in that place
um how difficult is it for them when
something like this happens because I've
said as I said before in you know the
last
hour it it these are split-second
decisions they're having to make
absolutely and of course in Upper
uppermost in the minds of offices will
be that terrible incident back in
2017 when they weren't on police there
at the gates of Parliament and we had
the tragic death of PC Keith Palmer who
bravely as it were died defending
Parliament now that's changed uh
Parliament
um but yes officers will have to make
very Split Second decisions and I think
perhaps in many parts of the world in
such a situation you could well have got
the police opening fire on the vehicle
when they saw it was approaching Downing
Street they have to make that decision
and clearly in this case they made the
right decision they moved quickly
apprehended the individual concerned and
there will be a review there will be a
debrief to make sure that everything
went as it should have done but I think
the the police officers at the moment
involved can say
hopefully a job well done and I can see
the picture breaking up here a little
bit
yeah well um we can um don't worry about
that we are on pictures of the car at uh
parked at that gate okay keep it on the
car yeah um but um
I mean that incident you mentioned 2017
that will have led I assume to changes
in the way that Parliament and Downing
Street here are protected well I think
that's always been the case at Downey
Street you've always had those on police
there but with that the incident back in
um there's still questions being asked
about that for example uh our police
announced Nation permanently of the
gates but then they weren't and the Word
was of course the MPS and
parliamentarians didn't like the um the
presence of armed police being
permanently there they found it a bit
oppressive well obviously after that
particular incident that all changed and
we've now got armed officers permanently
at the gates but of course they stand
there for a long time that they are
relieved of course they do go for breaks
but at just that level of concentration
that you need to do that sort of job uh
having to be conscious at any minute any
second you need you may need to spring
into action and make very very important
decisions
um not not a position I'd like to be in
but today the decisions were the right
ones and no one's been hurt
and as I say we've been all breather
side relief and we await further
information from them as to exactly what
went on which I'm sure will be
forthcoming
um in the near or maybe not quite the
near future we might have to wait until
tomorrow but um and of course this isn't
the first things that have been other
instances haven't there examples around
Buckingham Palace for example where
there's been security concerns there and
again we've seen the police respond very
promptly to those incidents
um dealing with the situation and again
resulting in no one being hurt so all in
all uh despite all the stick police are
getting if we look back over these
incidents I think the armed protection
unit of the met and their uniform
colleagues can fill at the moment pretty
well satisfied with this afternoon's
work but there will still be a review
there will still be a debrief and I'm
sure from somewhere critics will be
popping up saying well they could have
done this better all that better but
generally speaking a satisfactory
afternoon's work I think
yeah just finally because what we can
say is that things have happened pretty
quickly in terms of White Hall reopening
in terms of the police making a
statement saying that it is local
Westminster police uh who are dealing
interviewing with this interviewing this
man and in terms of them saying that at
the moment it is does not involve
counter-terror officers so they've
they've clearly you know decided pretty
quickly
um what what they make of this yeah
absolutely I mean they would have
obviously uh got the man out of the car
pretty quickly and they would have
assessed the situation they would have
assessed him as any police officer does
when when you're making an arrest and
they would have come to some initial
conclusions uh as to exactly what's
occurred as I say maybe the gentleman
Brazil maybe he's got mental and health
issues but there will be communication
obviously with counter-terrorism can the
terrorist police but at the moment it
will be the local detectives that will
be in interviewing this man but as I say
lots of checks will be going on lots of
work will be going on in the background
and there will be constant communication
with the counter-terror police until
it's decided that there's absolutely no
terrorist link to this particular
incident at all but everyone will be
working together in the same boat
pulling in the same direction and
hopefully as I say we'll get some more
information into calls absolutely Chris
thank you very much for uh
coming on Sky News this evening I
appreciate it Joe Pike is down
at uh ground level in Whitehall go what
uh give us an idea of what's going on
now
calm now Mark but what a contrast to 20
past four this afternoon when this a
great care a hashback hatchback was
driven into the gates of Downing Street
arms met police officers responding uh
pretty fast opening the doors of those
cars of the car to apprehend the
individual and the driver's seat and
shouting get back get back at members of
the public who as usual were crowding
but around the gates Downing Street are
taking pictures the police moving very
fast to create a cord and create a
sterile Zone all the way down Whitehall
one so they could get going with the
investigation work out what will happen
but also to work out what the risk was
to the public and to themselves from
this individual and their vehicle of
course we know in recent years cars have
been used as a weapon in central London
by terrorists just look back to 2017 in
the Westminster Bridge attack six six
people killed in that attack four
pedestrians hit by a car as well as PC
Keith Palmer
at the House of Commons the sixth person
being the terrorist but a police well
aware here that cars can be incredibly
dangerous even though it doesn't look
like from the video Sky News has
obtained that the car was moving
particularly fast and it was coming we
think from the other side of Whitehall
this road in central London where a lot
of government buildings are based if we
look across the roads we can see the
gates to a car park it appeared from
that video as if the the car was being
driven from that car park that car park
actually the backyard of the ministry of
Defense as well as New Scotland yards
the headquarters of the Met police and
also Richmond house which is another
government building Parliamentary
Building at different points this is a
secure area you can see a police van in
there at the moment people who are
parking there and driving cars out of
those Gates would of course be be vetted
security checked unlikely to be working
either for the Met police or for the mod
or for somebody in government or in
Parliament unclear at this stage why the
individual drove their car into the
gates of course it was I think a
frightening moment for all those
involvements the police officers but a
number of people are trying to deliver a
petition the door of Downing Street
members of the public taking part in the
Democratic uh process but the police
used to acting very fast we know Richard
zunak the Prime Minister was inside he
left soon after with his motor K Jeremy
Hunt the chancellor was also there the
fact though that the investigation is
not being run by counter-terrorism
officers but by the borough Force by
Westminster that police
boroughs separating different parts of
of the force I think shows they don't
think this is a a hugely serious
incident they investigation though is
ongoing we have seen items being taken
out of the boot of the car by officers
wearing blue forensic gloves we've also
seen them putting those items into
plastic evidence bags photos being taken
of the car and about 20 minutes ago a
large met police van with a crane on the
back are turned up this truck we
presumed was to take this silver Kia
away
the car has been taken away for the
moment but we presume that in the coming
hour or so this Silver gear is taken
away it's hard to see from here but it
doesn't look like Mark like the airbag
has inflated so even though this would
have been a frightening incident and of
course it sounded loud it doesn't
necessarily look like the car has been
driven at speed certainly not fast
enough to initiate the airbag going off
one individual arrested on suspicion of
criminal damage and dangerous driving no
injuries and yet but that investigation
is ongoing the car remains here although
we understand the prime minister is now
no longer on the estate Whitehall is
open uh cars bikes buses going up and
down very different uh to a couple of
hours ago uh rush hour is never normally
like this Mark in central London but
certainly the mood now here the calm
mood police officers looking reasonably
relaxed so different from the very tense
perhaps even frightening situation at 20
past four when that car was driven to
the front Gates of Downing Street are
met police officers reacting are very
fast I think to apprehend the individual
yep certainly seems that way Joe thank
you very much indeed joining me now is
former deputy assistant commissioner at
the Met police Stephen Roberts thank you
for being with us and uh Stephen what
what is your impression of what uh has
happened here
I suppose above all uh my impression is
of the the calm and the professionalism
of those officers on the gate at Downing
Street here we are what two hours and 20
minutes after the incident and normality
has been restored no shots have been
fired nobody has been injured uh and
life has gone back to normal thank
goodness uh those officers were faced
with a difficult challenge
um they didn't know what that car
contained it might have contained
somebody who was armed it might have
contained explosives it might have
contained a suicide bomber who was
simply going to drive up to the gates uh
and detonate a sizable bomb uh but they
reacted quickly they reacted calmly and
thank goodness we have a peaceful
outcome
yes you're absolutely right I can think
of many parts of the world where there
would be uh shots fired in this
situation certainly so I mean what goes
through the mind of these officers
because they they are trained to deal
with the terror attacks which you know
the the alert is still uh the threat is
still substantial we're told a terror
attack likely so this is going through
their minds constantly uh during their
working hours so it must be very
difficult what goes through their minds
when something like this happens because
they've got to make not only a
split-second decision but they've got to
try and make the right decision
absolutely right and many years ago I
was a an armed Protection Officer myself
in in plain clothes looking after the
Home Secretary it is
a rather odd mixture of Duty in that for
the vast majority of the time yes it's
really quite tedious because you're
standing there doing nothing you're
accompanying your principle just walking
along beside him but all the time you've
got to remain overt you've got to remain
in a state where you can move from being
calm quiet and frankly bored to Split
Second decision are you going to draw
and use your firearm
um what have you got to do to protect
your principal these officers on the
gate some inside and some outside of the
gate had that decision to face and from
everything that we can see and from
everything that we know so far they made
precisely the right decision and
as a number of commentators have already
said there are many places around the
world where shops would have been fired
and we've seen this over and over again
officers on protection at Buckingham
Palace officers on protection in and
around white people who've absolutely
maintained their Palm
yeah are you surprised they've opened
White Hall while the car is still there
uh no not particularly uh the car has
been examined the officers are
satisfied that it presents no danger
there's no reason not to open white ball
restoring normality is actually quite an
important part of counterterrorism
part of the
um the function of terrorism is to
terrorize the frightened people to put
people in a state where any incident can
be seen as threatening and that
um amplifies the impact of any terrorist
act that that does take place so
reacting calmly to an incident like this
is very important it sends a message
that London is a secure place it's a
calm place it's a peaceful place
okay Stephen thank you very much indeed
we're joined now by the conservative MP
for Bournemouth East chair of the House
of Commons defense select committee
Tobias Elwood uh thanks very much indeed
for being with us and I just wonder
first of all what you make of this
yeah can I just Echo the comments made
there
um no police officer knows how their day
is going to unfold and what we saw today
was huge professionalism right across
the board keeping a very calm and
measured approach in dealing with what
could have been something very very
different indeed we're still waiting to
learn more about what took place the
mental state of this driver his
nationality for example what the motive
was was it premeditated did he act alone
was this a distraction for example to
Usher the Prime Minister and others
others to Checkers or simply an
attention seeker there is so much still
to learn and the police will be
considering all this and uh more uh but
it does seem to be that uh this is
Terrorism has been ruled out I was
surprised I have to say to see your
reporter so close to the vehicle uh
itself but uh cleaning adjustment has
made that it is
safe I'm pleased to an incredible job in
dealing with this from an operational
perspective but I'd also give a shout
out to our intelligence agencies too
that are able to preempt so many
potential attacks closing down before
they've even got going and uh I think
we're very very grateful to what happens
in the UK in the manner of our policing
but it's worth remembering that this is
an iconic Landmark uh just as uh there
wasn't the terrorist event that I was
involved in in 2017 these are uh symbols
of British democracy known across the
world therefore obviously potential
targets for attacks of one form or
another but they're also very busy
functional buildings where
parliamentarians the Prime Minister
government officials need to go about
their business and it's the police
that's sit there stand there operate
there being able to make these very very
Swift individual judgments as to whether
any person is simply they wanted to have
their picture taken and they're just
transitioning by or indeed pose a real
and present threat that they then need
to deal with
yeah and you you mentioned the attack uh
Tobias in 2017 and you were
um involved in that as you
tried helped try to save the life of a
police officer who'd been stabbed this
must uh incidents like this must must
bring that day back to you
yeah it does firstly again going back to
the police so much has changed we want
to keep our Parliament open we want to
have a connection connectivity if you
like with the the British people of the
Democracy But ultimately there were huge
great big gaps in our security
um you touched on what I was doing there
trying to save the life with others of
PC Keith Palmer and I recall that the
gates the main Carriage Gates into
Parliament remained open the entire time
indeed a A dispatch
um driver on his moped drove in uh saw
what was going on and then drove back
out again it was one of the very strange
memories I have of the day this you know
where was the big button that you
pressed that closes all gates at the
emergency you know emergency
measures go right across the estate to
close everything down I'm pleased to say
that is now the case there are more
officers more checkpoints uh there's
much much sense of of uh security than
there ever uh was before if I have one
concern I saw this the other day we
still have the ability to have
demonstrations right outside those very
same Gates where demonstrators can have
pop-up awnings tents and so forth that
MPS and staff and indeed the public have
to Wade through
um they of course don't mean us harm but
anybody that does will be watching the
protocols they'll be watching what
happened how people interact or what is
allowed or what isn't allowed and I do
believe that whilst we've built up our
security capability with inside the
Parliamentary estate and inside their
area is around number 10. uh what
happens out on Parliament Square still
needs to be Revisited because I'm sad to
say this another attack could easily
take place yeah
all right Tobias uh thank you very much
indeed for uh joining us and uh
and as I say it does bring back that uh
that moment that attack in 2017. thank
you very much indeed for uh being with
us let's just go to Rachel venables who
is down there at the scene and uh Rachel
just as we approach the end of the hour
just give us a sense of what's happening
there
well at the moment what we're waiting
for is the tow truck the pickup truck
which arrived an hour or so ago to
actually remove the vehicle I think in
the last few minutes the police seem to
have taken off the license plate from
that silver Kia which is still parked
where it crashed into the gates of
number 10 Downing streets a little while
ago a tow truck arrived parked alongside
and we're expecting at some point
possibly in the next few hours maybe
sooner for this vehicle to be taken away
and at that point the last chord and the
final chord which is just outside the
immediate Gates of Downing Street will
be taken away and this area will get
back to normal what is normal for this
part of London which is of course one of
the most heavily guard did heavily
policed parts of the capital parts of
the country really parts of the world
and that explains really the severity
with which the officers the armed
officers who were here guarding the
space in which the Prime Minister was
the chancellor was at 20 minutes past
four when that car drove slowly across
the road and into the gates of Downing
streets very much the investigation of
course ongoing with that man a man under
arrest at the moment are being
questioned by police
Rachel thank you very much indeed so
just to
bring you up to date a man has been
arrested on suspicion of criminal damage
and dangerous driving after the vehicle
you see there was driven into the gates
of Downing Street it's a silver Kia car
crash into the gates around 20 past four
uh this afternoon
police say no one was hurt
the driver was arrested and it's
understood that local police are dealing
with it no counter-terrorism police
involvement at the moment after the
break a special program on immigration
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
good evening it's seven o'clock you're
watching at Sky News our breaking news
this hour as a car crashes into the
gates outside Downing Street one man has
been arrested
this is the scene live outside dining
street where the car remains in place
but police are not treating the incident
as Terror related
also this owl will bring you an
immigration ask the expert special here
on Sky News as net migration reaches new
record levels 606
000 more people arrived in the UK last
year than left the country will examine
social economic and political impact and
answer your question
thank you
it is a difficult day for the
governments that has promised to reduce
net migration but it was left the
immigration Minister not the Home
Secretary to face questions in the
Commons
conservatives have no plan and no grip
on immigration where is the Home
Secretary who is in charge of these
policies
balancing the needs of business we hear
from companies still desperate for
workers
very difficult for us to fit this
position the position has been open for
at least a year and to this day is still
open
but there are questions and concerns in
communities across the country is there
a plan to provide more homes schools and
hospitals
I mean they should think about all these
things before allowing large numbers you
know
because I think they should look after
us who are already living here
good evening I'll be joined by our panel
of experts to discuss today's migration
figures shortly but first those events
at Downing Street here's what we know so
far a man who's been arrested after a
car hits the main gates of Downing
Street police said there were no
injuries the Prime Minister was in
number 10 at the time of the crash Sky
News understands that the chancellor
Jeremy Hunt was also in Downing Street
now counter-terrorism police say they're
not involved in the investigation and
the road is now open again well let's
cross live to the Sea and bring in our
correspondent rate